okay welcome everyone to our class
tonight and the theme of this class is
on a middle game and basically as soon
as you develop all your pieces in castle
what to do basically in the middle game
idea so here I'll show you one of my
latest games about the middle game so
you can see how I managed to break
through and win relatively quickly in
this game okay
so in this game I'm playing with a white
pieces against a pretty strong player 24
2400 player so I play the move d4 and
this is a move that I normally play my
opponent played d5 c4 now he played a
six so at the moment it looks like he's
going to play Queens gambit declined but
actually it can also switch it could be
something else something different as
well like if you place the move c6 later
so we don't know yet exactly the hope it
looks like it's gonna be Queens gambit
declined but actually it can transpose
to some other openings so for example if
you play the move Knight c3 now he has
couple of options you can play the move
c5 and if you place the move c5 you know
this opening what is the name of this
opening here yes yes this is going to be
the teresh defense this is very
interesting opening not very popular but
you still white needs to know what to do
against it so that could be a terrorist
Irish defense and also he can also play
c6 this is another idea that set up the
pyramid and then later try to play a
five to get a stone wall structure is
you see the structure this is a
basically he's trying to play the spawn
wall when you see his pawns are set up
like that this is the Stonewall
structure okay so there are a couple of
options it looks like it's going to be
Queen's game
decline but it could be some other
opening so I was expecting him to play
this move but that's why I went Knight
f3 first Knight f3 first so if you place
c6 I have some additional options such
as Queen c2 III even Knight b d2 is
playable since i haven't developed my
knight on c3 i have this option to go to
on d2 so my opponent played Knight f6
developing is not very normal move so I
played Knight to c3 and here he has a
couple of options here he can play c6
which is going to be which opening semi
Slav defense yes if he plays Bishop e7
this is going to transpose to so it's
also good to get familiar familiar with
each opening so this is Queens gambit
declined correct that's another option
and if he takes on c4 rehan a Vienna and
now we come to what my opponent played
here he played Bishop b4 this looks very
similar to the nimzo-indian defense
opening but the name of this opening is
a little bit different any ideas what
might be the opening for this what is
black trying to play here yes this is
called ragas in defense okay so it's
very interesting it's pretty sharp lines
after dragazine so white needs to know
what to do against it because piece is
trying to be very active pinning the
knight and also always you have to watch
out with ideas Knight e4 activating the
knight and pulling pressure so I have to
you know you have to be a little bit
careful so I was a little bit surprised
because when I was preparing for my
opponent and we always do before the
game we search to see what opening key
plays and try to prepare for the game
and
you never play this opening so this I
didn't see any games in a database about
him playing like this so I was expecting
actually the semi Slav which was his
main opening but he surprised me a
little bit with this so I took my time
here a little bit and to figure out what
to play to make sure I get you know
reasonable position out of the opening
so you can play Bishop g5 here or you
can play some other moves but it took C
takes d5 I just want to clarify this the
situation in the center so my pawn is
not hanging and I don't have to worry
about what kind of structure we're going
to have basically after this take we
sort of know what type of structure is
it so I have my five pounds here it has
an extra pound on the queenside
sort of so it's a called we're going to
get this calls about structure okay so
if I go III c6 this leads to the dat
calls but structure here but I don't
want to play III of course here because
then I have a terrible Bishop here
blocked in so which move you supposed to
do here before you lock in your Bishop
because if you lock in your Bishop then
you have a passive Bishop you don't want
to have passive bishop so you need to do
which move first yes Bishop g5
activating the bishop and pinning the
Queen and then I can play the move III
then I don't have to worry about having
the passive Bishop so he played 9b d7
Rocco Singh is a pretty a pretty popular
opening there is lots of theory theory
is like basically there are a lot of
other games played that you can find in
a database and search I don't have that
much experience against it because I
don't normally get to play against it
too much but this was a moment for me to
test something that I prepared before
the most common move of course is III
but then this leads to some sharp
variations after c5 for example
and white is maybe a little bit better
but it's quite unclear so that's why I
wanted to play something different here
so I'm going to give you a couple of
options here please raise your hand if
you have if you think you know the move
that I played here it's not the most
obvious move I'm trying to complicate
the position a little bit early to see
if I can get some opening advantage here
he has this pin which is quite annoying
some potential threats of 94 in some
point if you if it moves my bishop away
yes Quimby 3 it's possible Muppets the
theoretical move Queen B 3 leads to a
very sharp position after c5 then you
take then he jumps in on a 5 with the
Queen and it goes on like this again a3
Bishop c3 okay yeah Queen B 3 is
possible but there are a lot of moves
here Queen c2 is possible
Roxy 1 I played before mainly different
moves here but which one is the Moodle I
play which move I played here huh and
immediately this was excellent idea
because his reaction he started to think
for a very long time and started to play
not the best moves because he was not
familiar with this idea 92 of course
92 is the move that I played which is a
lot of obvious move here but immediately
this move creates a threat do you see
the threat do you see which threat now I
have yes absolutely let's say he's not
paying attention I simply take the pawn
on d5 and now we take the Queen here
okay he cannot take this because his
queen is pinned so that's why he can add
her so immediately I have a threat my
opponent started to think here when he
spent a lot of time I realized he does
another move here and the move here is
c6 c6 protecting d5 this is what he
should do the best move in this position
but this would this would lead to a type
of position that I am pretty comfortable
I played for a very long time so at 83
then he castles we should be 3 I Castle
then I go Queen c2 to be able to put
pressure ok this is what I was aiming
for in this position but since he
started to think a lot and it looked
looked like he was not sure what to do
he took
is this a good idea to take the night
what do you think
no why who can tell me why it's not a
good idea to take on c3 here why you
think it's not a good idea to take on c3
okay loses the bishop here and also we
know that the bishops are worth a little
bit more correct
Auguste very good point my pawn comes
closer to the center and remember yeah
so now see my pong a little closer now
I'm a little bit stronger in the center
and most important thing now I obtained
the pair of the bishops and the bishops
are worth more in the opening what is
the value of the bishop in early stages
of the game three in a quarter three and
a quarter remember bishops are worth
more okay so that's why you have to try
to appreciate your bishops and here I
didn't even have to play the move a 3
which is amazing I actually would have
wasted another move to play a 3-2 to get
the bishops but actually he just
voluntarily give me the pair of the
bishops so this is a very nice advantage
now for me okay
I'm sure you have a question you have
question no ok so takes now he played
the move c5 this is the idea he had now
do you see now what is it trying to do
after this move he is trying to get
active here he gave up the pair of the
bishops but he has some ideas this is a
good player I mean it's it's a solid you
know strong player what is his idea
c4 I'm not sure because c4 will allow me
to maybe play e4 and break the center ok
so I'm not quite sure if c4 is a big of
a threat here it's trying to do
something else
c5 move allow the mid open up some
fools for him to get more active here
now what would move now he has in
addition yes very good very good
now for example if I play the movie III
Queen a5 now not only now he is
attacking me my bishop is becoming more
ineffective here because I'm no longer
pinning him see my bishop is not very
active anymore and this now I have to
worry about protecting this which is not
so easy because I use the Queen then he
takes then he jumps in he's getting more
active now okay so immediately I took my
time this is important because I believe
many players would instantly play the
movie three here because thinking okay
this this cannot be the this gotta be
the best move here but if you look a
little bit deeper into the position you
will realize that this Queen a5 is quite
annoying and maybe you should do
something to prevent that move from
happening absolutely that's the mood and
I played Queen a4 I anticipate his Queen
a5 so I just put my Queen here to
control that square and now he cannot
activate his Quin there anymore
and if he goes cream b6 that will fail
into rugby one again time temple so he
castled even though I'm a little bit
behind his pieces are not that active to
be able to take advantage of the fact
that I'm a little bit undeveloped so I
play the move III strengthening my
Center and getting ready to develop my
bishop now he plays h6 questioning my
bishop here
now what to do here you have couple of
options three possible moves here Bishop
takes Knight Bishop drop to f4 or Bishop
to h4 keepin the pin this is the moment
where you have to know sort of which
decision to make when you have three
different options and none of them look
that bad now they will kind of all of
them look kind of similar to each other
but which one is the best
which move you think normally what's the
best thing to do here in this kind of
positions haha why why do you like [ __ ]
page four instead of let's say Bishop f4
Oh Bishop f6
okay so Bishop f6 we don't want to go
because I mentioned to you the value of
the bishop right is three and a quarter
right so we don't want to give up the
bishop like that easily unless we gain
something you know structure we weaken
the structure or something right so
that's the that's the idea here yes
absolutely a bishop age for keeping the
pin when you have bishops
the advantage of having bishops is that
you can pee any pieces with right Bishop
f4 it's just too soft because not really
doing much they're not creating any
threats Bishop d6 is just an attack it
goes rook e8 nothing really going to
happen after that so that's why we play
Bishop h4 in order to keep the pin so
[ __ ] page four is absolutely when you
have bishops you want to keep them to
pin with okay use the bishops to pin
with remember pin it to win it that's
the idea when you have bishops then you
have better chances to pin upon it
pieces now of course g5 it's something
we will welcome very we will be very
happy if opponent plays g5 because after
this is going to be too many weaknesses
around the King so we will definitely
welcome a move like g5 here okay because
it will really weak in his position he
didn't do that is it solid players that
I rookie eight developing now another
important moment in this game here it
looks like moves are kind of easy to
play but not so clear here I have couple
of options here
I need to develop my light-square bishop
obviously in order to castle but I have
too many options and how to choose which
one is the best here again we have
Bishop to d3 we have Bishop to e2 we
even have a Bishop b5 ultra aggressive
move here but which one is the best to
play can you figure out out of these
three options but you also have to
explain your thoughts about why you're
choosing a one over another because they
look pretty good all three of them all
three of them look pretty good okay
let's give you a chance Andre what do
you think is the move here yes Bishop b5
that's a possibility now you have a pin
this group looks very aggressive in the
beginning but once you find a very
strong move for black here you realize
perhaps the bishop here is going to be a
little bit misplaced you know because we
already want to take the knight because
then you lose your bishop advantage this
move is good unless black plays this
move if you find the correct move for
black then this move it's not going to
be as powerful let's flip the board for
a second here and imagine you are
playing this position with a black piece
here and you are pinned now now it's
like a cross pin one bishop is pinning
this way h-hold another one on b5 so
you're very active here but there is one
move here one move here
what to do here one move to solve these
problems yes he is trying to play simple
do you see the threat though he
suggested to move with a very strong
threat now and the threat is take your
knight the problem you have now you
cannot take with a knight your rook is
hanging you take with a queen your piece
is hanging and if you take with this
structure is damaged okay so this Bishop
e5 is strong unless you find a correct
move here for black of course Knight b6
it's okay but after Queen here you lose
your pawn rook is hanging pawn is
hanging so you lose pawn so you need a
good move here see like for blitz this
would be a very good move for blitz you
play this in a blitz opponent is likely
to go wrong because it's not so clear
yes here Knight
yeah Knight you are your clothes
you are close he's your idea is right
but you have to make sure it's not
losing anything yes correct
Luke is six very good and now we realize
that this bishop won't be five not going
to do that much because we don't really
want to take here because he takes and
actually we might have to do that later
so you have to be careful okay so under
you realize your idea now it's actually
you know a lot of games this would have
actually helped you win a game but
unless your opponent finds the move so I
was playing a good player so I expected
him to find it that's why I didn't play
there should be five but in blitz
definitely you go Bishop e5 and it's
likely your opponent will blend or
something because rookie six is not easy
move to file
it's not easy moved fine if you're under
you know time pressure or something so
so which rule did I play now we come to
the moment where which move did I play
here so Bishop b5 was interesting but I
didn't play that now how do we choose
now we go for which move here okay all
right well there should be three you
have a point
Bishop d3 obviously I was considering
that move but I but I played Bishop e2
because Bishop d3 c4 tempos remember you
lose temples and chess it's all about
tempos remember see you say it something
very fast but what was your idea after
this okay
it's very concrete here so it's very
fast you know very concrete here you now
block your queen back home
your queen cannot get back home here
that's the problem see and if you go
Bishop b1 to play the clever Queen c2
idea unfortunately now this this guy is
a little bit trapped here and you don't
really have a threat that Knight is
covering the square you don't want to
play with the look like this okay okay
so there yes
we're on is also possible move to put
pressure here but here I want to develop
the bishops racking castle remember step
number three so you got to get the King
safety right so this kind of moves you
played after you get your bishop out and
you castle you cannot think about that
when the king is in the middle of the
board because then you can go get caught
in the middle of the attack and or some
fireworks so you'll be in trouble so you
go Bishop e2 first okay let's flip the
board now so you have it from the whites
perspective here so now he played he
spent a lot of time here and I could see
that he wasn't very comfortable in his
position so every move was like a
challenge for him every move was like 10
minutes think 15 minute think 20 minute
thing
so when opponent does that that means he
is not very comfortable and I can
understand why because in this position
it's not easy to make moves it's very
hard to know which move is the right
move here so he plays the move c4 so he
Latin that tells us that I made the
right decision because he wants to play
c4 anyway so if he played c4 with the
bishop on it - he was definitely going
to play this one when I put the bishop
on d3 gaining the important tempo on my
bishop so I drew so he played here now
what's next move
for White Castle safety of the King
remember is in number one priority
I always repeat this you know but it's
very very important that you cancel
before you try to do any kind of
tactical ideas or anything so castle
safety of the King always counts as your
number one priority okay now he played
the move a six he is threatening to play
b5 an attack my queen
okay he wants to play b5 attack my queen
now I need to make a good move here this
is a middle game now for you right here
after I Castle middle game you will see
in just couple of moves I managed to win
this game
I mean mostly because he blundered but
still finding the plan was important
here now he is threating to play b5
attacking your queen we know that's
going to happen here we are anticipating
that what you supposed to do here Mike
Mike suggested Roux kb1 but after b5 you
will take yeah yes 96 but Mike Mike
Scott this no take you saw that Mikey
okay
he had that he had that covered guys
okay well the problem is he will just
move his rook and do that same thing
next and attack you okay so he will move
away and attack you okay
I gotta move my queen here I gotta move
my queen because the queen is going to
get attacked okay
Queen is going to get the tax so we have
to try to move somewhere okay so we
don't get attacked and actually if it
does something then we can attack him so
think about it what to do here to to
move to make a prophylactic move here so
we can attack him after okay
so we can attack him after now think
about it yes
Quincy tun is a move that everybody
would play it's a standard move but I
want more you know don't just play
standard like most people would do then
he plays b5 then he goes Bishop e7 okay
you have a point so this move you will
go here I don't know b5 a4 yeah yeah I
agree with you then in here I agree this
this you're better here because I can
get my bishop out because I lose upon I
agree with you rook FP one it's a bit
bit long-term move you know locking the
rook like that you know that's that's
not very easy to anticipate but what if
he just goes b6 and B should be seven I
mean if he's just trying to just get his
things over with here
the small part of me wants to play
Michigan with very small part well we
should be seven yeah then they should be
selfish why now we should be seven
maybe you can take a small way it's
funny he cannot take any of the poems
yeah you don't see this too often it
takes with this guy drops the bishop
this way it takes the Tsukiji up this
okay very interesting very interesting
yeah see this is what's happening when
you analyze the position deep enough you
find a lot of ideas that you actually
didn't think of during the gap
interesting I would put an interesting
symbol after this move okay
I think my move is probably more direct
to the point but look everyone deserves
attention okay it's very interesting
that deserves attention now let's see
I'm still waiting for you to find my
move here because you know you wants to
play b5 and with idea off when from
going to 85 all we have more happy very
good thinking very good thinking yes
Queen before it's very important for you
to learn to anticipate okay to
anticipate opponents ideas so here we
see it's time to play b5 we go Queen
before we move away so if you place B
file we're going to get in with a four
and put pressure on it
got it and he has to play B Phi because
it plays b6 after a four Rock fp1 and
this is just weak
okay so he played here b5
absolutely for when you choose a plan
you stick with it remember do you guys
do that in chess you always do that you
choose a plan you stay with it now
now something could you know something
strange happen here my opponent who made
the move after which I responded with
the move and he resigned would you ever
guess that this game will be over in one
move it was a 16 move miniature one of
the shortest victories ahead in a while
so he made a move thinking that this is
interesting idea he's going to get some
momentum but actually it was a pawn
blunder after which he just didn't even
want to continue no that's too obvious
it stinks no the Queen b6 that's too
obvious no he okay he could have just
taken here and accepted that his words
but we're still fighting here okay so he
didn't do that he didn't do that so he
played the move
he played a5 yes good job
of course now but why why is this such a
bad move here who can see we can
calculate deeply here and find the
victorious move for white don't rush
think again twenty four twenty feet a
player missed it so it means it's little
subtle I know it's little subtle you
know that he missed it
it's little subtle
after
excellent thinking very good so I took
on b5 I show the idea you know so I
actually showed this many pain I was
like really is it gonna do this I took
it but you have to calculate in a
middlegame this what tells you things
can get quickly very concrete in a
middle game so here you see I have to
take now now he attacks me okay attacks
my rook now and now Bishop f6 you got it
yes now he takes back with the night
thank you very much for the book we're
winning this if it takes back with the
Queen do we take the pawn and we take
another pawn okay this is going to get
really serious now okay okay we'll just
make one defensive move here and then
start collecting the material a 5-pound
c4 pound we win all these puns and if it
takes with this obviously we'll be very
happy with grabbing the pawns here
so here I had to calculate of course
this variation now takes rook b2
attacking this bishop takes
texts attacking the bishop we should
have 396 protecting it where okay I just
got bishop here push the palm slowly I
will convert this into win
no questions okay slowly we will convert
this into a win got it
questions Oh will you interesting but
now I'm not saying it doesn't work but
oh okay I take I mean this is schedule
the complex know why get into the
complexity look at this now let's not to
get this too complicated okay cuz here
yet to complicate it even for yourself
sometimes it's not good because then you
wouldn't know what to do right so yeah
don't keep it simple and keep it simple
that's my recommendation but-but-but
guys what about this this looks like
solving the problem just push the bishop
away and then play rugby eight no and
he's seeing it see very sharp
yes he's seeing it the rooks Bishop g3
now controlling the BH square
unbelievable yeah it doesn't work for
him
so bishop goes g3 and now b8 square is
taken if it goes to b8 just take Bishop
takes b8 and now if you place Bishkek
s-- simply go here and then Queen c2
very comfortable all right
so after I did this move my opponent was
not happy so he started shaking his head
and I sensed it that he might just
resign because no hope you know it's a
position if you can play but not really
a hope I mean okay resigning is bit bit
unexpected you know but I really thought
he might just resign and that's what
happened after about 10 minutes of
thinking he just stopped the clock and
say I designed yeah and one of the
shortest wins against the you know top
opponent like this 24 20 feet see the
master flesh alexander calyx chain his
name is from new york okay this is the
game against them so i wanted to show
you this and now we will do review and
make sure you remember the ideas of this
game okay opening and the middle game
raise your hand if you remember the
moves now first of all we start out with
the first move yes
continue yes next raise your hands yes
Knight f3
correct
yes
many different actions he played this
what is the name of this opening
everyone everyone in this room should
notice opening huh rug goes in rug goes
in defense ok and now you also learned
you also learn how to play against Lagos
and this was a combination of middle
game and learning another opening for
you how to deal with dragons in defense
and this is a very good way of dealing
it actually very very good way of
dealing against are Gaussian because
opponents are not going to be very
familiar with it ok so what's the move
that I play here to simplify the
position and make sure not too many
pounds are hanging and the structure is
structure is fixed
of course yes continue now you don't
want the bishop to walk in right what
you going to do first develop your
bishop remember develop first ok now he
goes here continue thinking thinking
Knight d2 explain the reason of this
move is this a decent move an
interesting suggestion yeah absolutely
and now immediately creating a threat of
Knight takes d5 ok thank you for the
pond right that's tidy he should play c6
years so he didn't know the line so he
opted for something improvising take
take and now this is the move who would
have find the move that I played here
what do you think in a real game
would you have anticipated his idea
after c5 yeah very very much it's likely
that Bishop e3 is the natural move but
now you know it now you add another idea
to your knowledge ok here today that not
always you play the most standard moves
in chess and here the correct move is
huh
reasoning star queen a five simple and
clear
stop opponent from getting activity
activities castle now light square
bishop needs to be developed
it cannot be developed with the pun only
two so what are we going to do in order
to achieve that age six questioning your
bishop yes keep the pin keep the pin
okay
don't let the palm push to deflect you
from there okay keep the pin when you
have bishops use your bishops to pin
opponent pieces knights and rooks
especially could get pinned rook e8 he
went now we have a choice we have three
different moves here to play here how
you going to choose which one is the
best which is the best move to make here
huh
huh
correct very good see for his lacking it
is locking with the position threatening
to play b5
in anticipation of b5 we play queen
before prophylactic move now he goes
here
raise your hands please if you know the
move raise your hands so now we opponent
be five pounds weak so we want to try to
put pressure on correct and how are we
going to do that absolutely
he plays a five now
blunder but even if he didn't blunder
his position is not very good actually
because I will be creating a witness of
course the blunder helped me to win
quickly but yeah he should have played
something like Group B 8 perhaps it's
worse but yeah so or take roque for
White is still better so he played the
move a5 and Queen takes p5 up goose now
he played rugby 8 attack gear design but
if you please repeat now what is the
move not yet not yet a5 is protected by
the Queen okay so we have to shake up
the defense here shake up the defense
and that's will do that that's well do
the Bishop f6 will achieve that because
now so many ways to recapture but he
cannot do anything all right okay since
we are on this topic here I want to
introduce you to a plan on a middle game
another additional idea for you to learn
since we are on the similar position
here so if he play C six we talked about
it that I want everybody to understand
this structure when you have versus this
this is called calls about the structure
okay
remember everybody understand calls but
structure now I will just make some
moves the moves are not particularly
important I just want to show you the
plan okay so you sort of get a position
like this and here in a cause but
structure if you study two games from
the tournament in calls but very famous
tormenting halls but you can look it up
they played a lot of this plants in that
tournament I think that's why the name
scape name comes from a calls but
what is the plan here for white you
probably have to be a default player to
know that or if you studied some of the
masterpieces from you know Kasparov
Karpov you know all this big champion
games you know Petrosyan between unique
you would remember this so what is the
plan here for white to achieve an
advantage and create weaknesses I know
this because I've been playing this
opening since I was five six years old
but raise your hands if you know the
plan here for white the most popular and
thematic plan in a cause bad system yes
close close but your first move you have
to do something else than a three of
course okay yes the plan is you start in
these positions always rotate I'll tell
you why if you play a three right I make
a move let's say you play B for correct
I play this move can you play b5 but you
understand what happened right
you played a tree and then you played a
for losing a tempo everyone and remember
chess it's all about temples okay
so that's why in a cause but structure
for you remember you start with rook a
be one first okay look a be one first
and now opponent for example place a
five he sees that you're gonna play d4
he's trying to anticipate your idea with
before what are you going to do to
continue with the course but plan here
cause about structures sorry the idea
again remember this name structure is
calls but the plan white is using its
called minority attack minority
attacking the majority
and when you finish with the attack one
way or another black will have a
weakness if he is not careful he can
even have two weaknesses and you will
see now it doesn't have weaknesses but
after you down with a minority attack he
will at least have one weakness
a5 is the correct move here for black to
prevent you from playing before how are
you going to continue with the plan here
yes
absolutely you play a tree now now he
goes 96 for example we go before take
take rook c8 v 5 now minority is
completed minority finished against the
majority now do you see the weakness now
do you see the weak pawn in the for the
black in this position backwards pawn
this is called in chess when the pawn is
not protected by another pawn and it's
fixed
we call that backwards pawn right so
that's a weak pawn right - very weak
pawn now and this will be a clear
advantage for white so see in this
position it looks absolutely fine for
black this position now the five moves
later he's got a backward pawn and he is
struggling and the way you deal with
this you go Knight a four you control
that Square make sure he cannot push the
backward pawn and then you put the rook
on c1 to pile up more pressure on c6 not
to mention the idea of not be sexier
comes in okay so it's a very very strong
idea here for why I mentioned that if he
is not careful he can even have two
weaknesses remember
let me explain to you how like let's say
it's the playable mole right somebody
takes now you take back with the rook
look at this now how many weaknesses he
has - he's got two weaknesses the palm
b7 is weak the pawn on d5 so he has two
weaknesses here and now it will be much
easier for you to win this game because
of two weaknesses so another idea here
he has to play a five if it doesn't play
for example that's something else you
play the move before he continues with
the same idea we play b5 another move
take again now how many weaknesses you
see for black here - it's much
easier for you to win again when
opponent has two weaknesses one weakness
sometimes it's not enough to win and a
lot of times when opponent has one
weakness you're struggling to find a way
to win the plan is to create the second
weakness
once opponent has two weaknesses then
you will stretch his position and he
won't be able to defend so remember one
weakness sometimes not enough and if you
cannot win with one weakness create the
second weakness okay so that's the idea
about minority attack everybody
understand this structure here everybody
know the name now for this structure for
white and block okay what's the name of
the structure calls but structure and
what's the main plan in the cross body
structure for white to obtain an
advantage minority attack how do we
execute the minority attack here what is
the correct move to start with here to
execute it properly
auguste specify which rook rook a b-1
not III as suggested earlier a3 as
possible but not the most accurate move
you started with luque b1 you're ready
to push before now create a weakness
before b5 so he plays a5 continue now he
stopped you from playing before now what
we need to do to prepare that because if
you play it yes a3 absolutely now
preparing to play before that's our plan
9g 6 continue yes before he captures you
capture rook c8 and remember in chess
when you choose a plan you stick with
the plan okay you don't change your mind
and try to do something else that's not
a good idea okay so you go for the plan
with b5 b5 if it takes this way to
weaknesses if it goes Queen d7 now
what do you do go ahead and now at the
end of the minority attack we see a big
weakness now backwards pawn on c6 pawn
that is weak and constantly need
protection so after we play Knight a for
rook fc-1 White has a better position so
today we will learn two important ideas
we learn Raggles in defense and ideas in
the middle game and we learn the middle
game of the de calais bot structure in a
Queens gambit declined and the minority
attack plan in a middle game these are
very important ideas for you if you are
a default player and if you are playing
these positions for block you will know
what to expect if opponent tries this
ideas on you